when I pull back out of the specificity
principle I leave more energy and I
leave more time for the proper practice
to happen yeah because the practice is
where the sportsman gets better here is
where the athlete gets better functional
training is a term that is thrown around
an awful lot but which is infamously
nebulous and hard to define this partly
explains the varied responses that we
see to the term with some seeing it as
the future of fitness another seeing is
a bunch of fools on rubber boards
spoiler I fall firmly in the former camp
so what is functional training and how
do you employ the strategies in your
workouts functional training has no
single definition generally though it
has agreed that functional training
means training for function you are
trying to improve functional capacity by
ensuring you can do the things you want
to do better or alternatively gaining
the ability to do more things functional
training can be generally divided into
two camps depending on your goals
training for specific athletic skills or
training to be more capable in everyday
life let's take a look at both athletes
can use functional training as a form of
complementary preparation alongside
their main practice to enhance their
performance in a given activity this
typically comes down to several things
training cost ability to facilitate the
transfer of power via the limbs training
explosiveness to develop greater speed
and power training proprioception to
enhance balance coordination and agility
training range of motion to prevent
injury and create more opportunities for
performance focusing on rehabilitation
to prevent injury of course there's more
to it than that this is a good starting
point and a good introduction to the
kinds of things you'll likely be doing
you and Carlos JC Santana is director of
the Institute of human performance how
cool is that named in his book
functional training he describes
functional strength the strength that
you can use on the field JC is also
careful to distinguish between
functional training and support specific
training we developed athleticism in gas
that's our job yeah okay once that
happens the sports coach is in charge of
the player you go alright Dave locomote
a lot
yeah I have to stabilize that single leg
plant and the seventh frame huge okay
they cut a lot so I gotta apply terminal
extension terminal triple extension knot
in the middle terminal with an inverted
and everted ankle right yeah what is
those little details so I've got my wall
slides and I've got my little exercises
that I can do it's very easily repaired
person that that is fairly specific to
the area it's pretty specific but I
think once you get it you go oh [ __ ] of
course it is and that's it I'm going
that's it functional functional training
is it's the the amount of training that
can be applied to a specific activity
okay the amount of training that's
outside of that realm can be general
that's your body building strength
training alright and your sports
specific which is basically the swinging
or something maybe with a heavier bad or
something like that all good stuff the
functional training is in the middle why
because it allows you to apply more
strength to that batting to the running
to the whatever it is that you're doing
and it's usually sandwiched between
general strength and sports specific
stocks it's like the it's like the link
between its enriched yes awesome and and
that so yep literally transferring the
strength to the movement perfect
developing the hip stability necessary
to move powerfully off of one leg
translates to greater running speed and
lower incidence of injury running is
categorized here as locomotion which is
one of the four big sports skills the
complete list looks like this
locomotion level changes pushing and
pulling rotation they also learn to use
them in tandem often emphasis here is
placed on neuromuscular adaptations more
so than hypertrophy for example we can
look at the way that the body transfers
power through the transverse plane via
the syrupy effect by using a cable the
individual is forced to brace their core
against the resistance and maintain
enough stability to then exert force via
the shoulders chest and delts over time
the athletes should theoretically adapt
and learn to engage their rotational
strength while also generating an
applying the necessary power this lets
them actually use the pushing power
they've developed in a useful manner and
this is applicable for an athlete's
swinging a bat or a racket thing is if
you only train with the big three lifts
you're doing nothing to develop a
rotational strength or single leg
strength likewise you won't improve your
mobility outside of fixed patterns or
learn to coordinate movements in other
ways but training with both heavy lifts
and this type of functional movement can
provide the maximum performance benefits
build that strength then learn to apply
that strength different coaches will of
course take different approaches
there'll be many similarities across
different gyms I highly recommend
checking out the ihp fits YouTube
channel
jaesi really knows his stuff I'll put
the link in the description down below
but how does functional training apply
to the general population outside of
athletes well if we use the same logic
the objective here would be to train in
such a way as to support everyday
activities that doesn't necessarily mean
mimicking everyday activities but rather
developing strength mobility and control
that can help us to perform them better
do you really need functional training
to go about your relatively low
intensity lifestyle
well functional training helps me
anytime I need to get up off the floor
in seconds regardless of what position I
was in previously because my daughter
has run off towards the kitchen
functional training also benefited me
recently when I was required to carry
heavy bags of cement then heavy fence
panels from the delivery van to our
house if this sounds familiar that's
because functional training is applied
to the general populace takes a lot of
keys from George's Herbert's natural
method or the method natural I'm sorry
if I butchered that pronunciation
George's spent time in the French
Marines in the early 1900s but after
coordinating the escape and rescue of
seven hundred plus people from disaster
he gained a renewed appreciation for the
importance of athletic skill and
performance to that end he developed a
system for complete physical development
influenced by the indigenous people he
observed in Africa he believed in being
strong to be useful which is at the core
of functional training his ideas would
go on to inspire parkour and mob NAT
he's also responsible for the military's
use of assault courses without George's
that probably wouldn't be Ninja Warrior
either George's wrote this the final
goal of physical education is to make
strong beings in the purely physical
sense
the natural method promotes the
qualities of organic resistance the
muscularity and speed towards being able
to walk run jump move on all fours to
climb to keep balanced to throw lift
defend yourself and to swim in the
veeraiah lore energetic sense the system
consists in having sufficient energy
willpower courage coolness and firmness
in the moral sense education by
elevating the emotions directs or
maintains the moral drive in a useful
and beneficial way the true natural
method in its broadest sense must be
considered as the result of these three
particular forces it is a physical
virile and moral synthesis it resides
not only in the muscles and the breath
but above all in the energy which is
used the will which directs it and the
feeling which guides it this is similar
in concept to the seven primal movements
as described by physiologist Paul check
push-pull squat lunge bend twist gait JC
is likewise developed a streamlined
version of this his four pillars of
human movement our locomotion level
changes pushing and pulling and rotation
and this of course is linked to the four
big sport skills in his book the
functional training Bible author Guido
Bashir outlines a distinction between
actions and functions the adductor
brevis might have the action of
abducting the thigh but one of its
functions is to help maintain hip
stability during normal walking gait to
train functionally we should focus on
walking with a movement like the farmers
walk rather than using the hip adductor
machine after all when do you ever need
to crush something between your thighs
such approaches tend to favor training
the whole body as a compound system
rather than isolating specific muscles
while there can be benefits to using
isolation and single joint movements we
rarely move that way in real life
training with only isolation movements
will often result in imbalances and poor
intramuscular coordination this is why
we often say things like kettlebells are
more functional that's because
kettlebells inherently involve more
muscles working at unpredictable angles
in real life there are no straight lines
and few constrained repetitive movement
patterns if you want strength that
transfers to everyday tasks you need to
be adaptable but to be clear this is a
spectrum and it's something that is
highly personal I don't agree with the
notion that bodybuilding style training
is non-functional
bodybuilding will make you stronger they
pack
not to the same degree as power lifting
and it will also increase your strength
endurance possibly more so than
powerlifting owing to the higher rep
ranges you're still increasing
functional capacity you can still be
more than you could before and if you're
a pro bodybuilder then there's no
training that is more functional for
your sport so it all depends on your
goals as for my goals my interests lie
in using functional training to develop
skills and abilities but I don't
necessarily need in my day-to-day life I
want to be able to planche flip kick
flying lift heavy weights and handstands
not because any of these skills are
required for my daily life but because I
want to explore the performance I'm
capable of because it's fun and because
it might one day come in handy I can't
understand people who say I don't need
to be faster or more stable you don't
need to be richer or happy or better
looking either how is having greater
physical capacity anything other than
awesome think about what else you could
accomplish if you had more energy and
more power and that's before we consider
the benefits that physical training have
on brain function mood or general health
isn't it cool to be more like the heroes
that we look up to on the big screen why
do most people who workout at gyms focus
purely on aesthetics or trying to lift
really big numbers in just three key
lifts hyperspecialization won't undo all
the damage they're sitting for 10 hours
a day does it just makes you better at
those lifts the human body's capable to
say much more surely it's better to
improve in as many disparate areas of
performance as possible even if you
don't become the very best to any one of
those things I don't just want to be
functional I want to be super functional
I don't want to be strong to be useful I
want to be strong to be awesome if you
feel the same way then be sure to check
out my ebook and training program super
functional training the link is in the
description down below and there's a
discount on wasp we'll all in lock down
it's a PDF that explains how to develop
body in mind in ways that most people
overlook drawing on concepts from
old-time strongmen
recent research martial arts and
countless forms and other training
thanks a ton for watching this video
guys if you found it useful and
interesting then please leave a like and
share it around let me know in the
comments down below what you think about
functional training and subscribe for
much more content like this hope you
guys are all safe and healthy and I'll
catch you in the next one thanks a ton
for watching and bye for now